families in gaza are mourning this
funeral is for yasir and napahin
he and his three children muhammad dalia
and ahmed
were killed in the beit hanoon home by
an israeli airstrike
not far away other palestinians are
surveying the damage
some have set up temporary shelters
others are trying to salvage their
possessions
three years three wars and we suffer
every time they bomb the house from a
different side once from the east ones
from the west once from the north
and every time they ask us to leave and
every time we suffered great fear
because israel says a hunt for leaders
of the palestinian islamic jihad
israel and its allies call them tourists
but the relatively small armed
resistance group enjoys support among
palestinians
the effect heavy aerial and arterially
attacks on neighborhoods in gaza and
retaliatory rocket fire into israel
egypt mediated the cease-fire between
israel and the islamic jihad with
support from the uan and qatar
islamic jihad has told al jazeera that
as part of the deal it has been assured
that senior members held in israeli
jails will be released something that
israel denies
we have a very clear decision that
without releasing khalid
and bassam assadi
there will be no ceasefire agreement
that will be a break for the agreement
from the israeli side and the fight will
be continued
ferguson's living under decades of
illegal occupation in an open-air prison
the latest ceasefire is just that a
brief pose until the next attacks
you
is the spokesman of the palestinian
islamic jihad in beirut he says egypt
has guaranteed two members of the group
will be released as part of the peace
deal israel denies that
says the group is ready to resume
bombing if the two aren't set free
that agreement announces that
have to be released today morning and uh
is to be released in
within two weeks now it's for the
egypt it's for egypt to announce
which one is right and which one uh is
saying the truth and what the agreement
really
had uh in its uh points we have a very
clear decision that without releasing
khalid
there will be no ceasefire agreement
that will be a break for the agreement
from the israeli side and the fight will
be continued now i think that
it's in the egypt hands
egypt has to say what was the agreement
and
how to deal with the situation
this is not the first time that the
israelis break the agreements
we know that and we believe that bennett
and lapid the government
had
to make victory at the polls at the
expense of the palestinian people at the
expense of the palestinian blood
i spoke to lynn hastings who's the un
humanitarian coordinator for the
occupied palestinian territory she says
a long-term solution is needed
the entire situation is a tragedy
our first concerns right now of course
that the ceasefire must hold
there were children who have been
growing up in gaza and have endured the
repercussions of five wars
i just want to say that both israelis
and palestinians need to be able to feel
safe
palestinians need to be able to exercise
their rights to movement
to education to be able to
get access to health care and to be able
to have jobs
every time there's an escalation these
goals are set back for both israelis and
palestinians going back to the beginning
of august here is not normal going back
to
2021 which
during which there was another
escalation that's not normal either we
really need to be looking for
longer-term solutions here well even
outside of the latest strikes how does
the continuing
israeli siege affect palestinian lives
well i think a number of the pictures
that you've already shown demonstrate
that and some of the things that i've
said
uh demonstrate that just in terms of
being able to exercise the rights that
you and i and so many of us are able to
enjoy all of the time they don't have
freedom of movement they're unable to
access economy they often are not able
to access the their health care all of
the things that most of us or many of us
at least are able to take for granted
at least 45 palestinians including 16
children have been killed how do you
think that can be justified
um well according to international law
of course children should never be put
in harm's way
anybody who is engaged in any type of
hostilities needs to ensure that the
use of force is proportionate to the
circumstances i also want to point out
of course that
the use of indiscriminate weapons
especially if they're coming from
well-populated residential areas and
landing in well-populated residential
areas are contrary to international law
israeli forces have demolished
palestinian homes during a raid in the
occupied west bank bulldozers
accompanied by israeli forces destroyed
two houses in the village of umane near
janine one belonged to the grandfather
of a twenty-year-old palestinian who was
accused of killing three israelis in
early may
is 17 kilometers northwest of the
palestinian city of janine the village
is home to around six and a half
thousand people neither ibrahim sent
this report from the demolition site in
ramani
this is what remains of the bihart
family home after israeli forces raided
the romani village and demolished the
house it belongs to the family of a 20
year old palestinian who has been
accused by israel of killing three
israelis in an attack in may the
grandfather of his bihar says this was
his dream home he worked abroad for 30
years and it was his dream to come back
here and build a three-story house but
now him and 16 other members of his
family
are homeless
the destruction of this building here
only increased hatred and not fear me my
children and grandchildren are not
afraid they are sowing the seeds of
hatred amongst the new generation i told
the israeli commander all occupations
will come to an end
the house of 19 year old assad referee
has been demolished as well
both men were detained in israel after a
three-day manhunt the families here say
they had no idea of their son's
intentions
i'm joined here now by the uncle of
assad
i want to ask you can you rebuild this
house
we can't even remove the rubble before
we get the approval of the israeli
occupation
we can't rebuild the house now eight
family members have lost their home and
have nowhere to go many here are telling
us that they're following the news of
the latest israeli escalation on the
besieged gaza strip and they say even
when a ceasefire has been reached the
israeli occupation its violations and
its measures are still ongoing